l'ouest et 17 qui fut de l'avis de tous
les experts en matière de blindés
le premier charme gouverne du monde
possède la même architecture que le char
leclerc ou plutôt si j'ose dire puisque
l'un est né avant l'autre le char
leclerc à la même architecture que le ft
17 en termes d'arrangement mécanique
c'est à dire que nous trouvons de
manière tout à fait classique un pilote
qui est à l'avant une trouvaille qui est
au milieu et un groupe motopropulseur
qui est kate à l'arrière donc il y a une
une
notion de filière technique tout à fait
avéré entre afp 17 et un char leclerc
évidemment pour le reste 80' de
technologie et de recherche sont passés
par là et il faut bien avouer que ce
bradage des 17 avec ses 7 km h de
vitesse de pointe et son petit village
de 15 mm n'a plus grand chose à voir
avec le monstre de technologie que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui en pleine guerre
froide la france avait lancé des études
pour remplacer la génération de chars
issu de la seconde guerre mondiale comme
les à mx 13 divers projets verront ainsi
le jour
parmi eux la mx 50 en juin de 60 tonnes
véritable chars lourds étaient équipés
de blindage incliné de forte épaisseur
d'un canon puissant de 120 mm d'un
moteur d'environ 1000 chevaux et d'un
système de chargement semi automatique
voilà unique 50 est un matériel que nous
avons conçu étudié au début des années
c'est pas pour ça qu'il appelle 50 c'est
pour sa masse c'est un matériel qui a
été finalement un des matériels qui ont
permis la rénovation de leur blindé en
france et c'est un matériel qui n'a
jamais été produit en série
la france s'oriente plutôt vers la
création d'un char moyens ceci aboutira
à la mise au point de la série des amx
30 au milieu des années 60 à la fin des
années 60 la france avait développé un
concept de charmoille un live mix 30
ce char d'un poids d'environ 30 tonnes
faisait partie de la classe des chars
classiques de l'époque comme le léopard
un allemand ou le thé 62 soviétique
rapidement cet engin va devoir évoluer
pour faire face aux différentes
améliorations des charges adverses comme
le t 72 soviétique
la mx 30 b2 line x32 et le système
brennus de plats traditionnels de
blindage réactif vont être des solutions
à court terme permettant d'améliorer
l'engin de base
cependant rapidement la nécessité de
concevoir un engin entièrement nouveau
va s'imposer
un engin capable de s'opposer dans les
plaines d'allemagne ou hors de danger
blindée du pacte de varsovie
la jeunesse du char leclerc remonte à
une plus d'une vingtaine d'années quand
l'état major français a décidé de
remplacer le char amx 30 bien connue
comme étant la masse de bataille blindée
du corps blindé mécanisée français qui
est essentiellement stationnés en
allemagne et le leclerc était conçu pour
en fait à l'origine contrer ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque les ors de
soviétiques comment imaginer est une
déferlante sans fin 2008 de chars et de
blindés venant de l'est
de plus les nouvelles technologies
utilisées sur le terrain comme
l'utilisation des hélicoptères de combat
remettait en question la conception
classique d'un engin de combat terrestre
en 1980 le projet napoléon tentative de
rassembler les compétences des
ingénieurs de chaque pays va essayer de
répondre à un cahier des charges précis
le nouvel engin devra se battre à 3
contre 1 en gagnant 4 bataille
technologique différentes
la bataille de l'information la bataille
des feux
la bataille de la mobilité la bataille
de la protection l'armée française
devait combattre dans un rappeur de
faire ce extrêmement défavorable que
l'on estimé de 3 à 1
en clair un char français qui étaient
engagés sur ce qu'on aurait pu appeler
le front de l'est pour nous français
devait être capable de se défaire d'une
menace constituée d'un peloton de chars
soviétiques c'est à dire trois chars
donc il fallait que ce char soit très
bien protégé pour encaisser les coups de
l'adversaire
et puis surtout tire plus vite que
l'adversaire et c'est comme ça que le
char leclerc est né ce projet n'aboutira
pas
la seule concession allemande étant de
proposer de donner au projet le nom de
napoléon le giat valeur se lancer dans
l'étude de ce qui sera appelé le pc ou
engins principal de combat donc à
travers ce cet acronyme epc engins
principal de combat la commission a bien
signifié que le l'action décisive sur le
champ de bataille revenait aux chars
rappelons ici qu'au même moment les
premières informations sur le merkava
commençaient à circuler que le léopard 2
était déjà en production et que les
premiers prototypes d'abraham ce
américain était testé la france était
donc très en retard le char leclerc est
un très très bon sujet en matière de
sociologie des techniques
il est évident que les industriels
avaient intérêt évidemment à ce que ce
char ça construit mais également les
militaires il était donc nécessaire par
rapport à la menace que faisait peser la
nouvelle génération de chars russes de
disposer d'un char capable de les battre
fort des études précédentes le giat va
alors cerné de façon définitive le futur
pc
un engin d'environ 50 tonnes de
conception terrestre classique avec une
tourelle une motorisation minimale de 30
chevaux par tonne soit 1500 chevaux un
canon de 120 mm aam lice pour rester au
standard franco allemand nous avons
réalisé six prototypes qui préfigurait
dans leur silhouette générale et dans
leur architecture générale ce que
deviendra le char leclerc produit en
masse dans notre usine de roanne de
manière tout à fait classique
programme de ce qu'on appelle de
qualification et d'essai d'un char ou de
tout autre système d'armes un peu
compliqué consiste à affecter à un
prototype une gamme de tests l'angélus
trompe répond vous avez un ou deux
prototypes qui sont classiquement
consacré à la mobilité
donc on va tester la mobilité de l'engin
dans n'importe quel type de terrain sous
n'importe quelle latitude sous n'importe
quel type de conditions météorologiques
il va y avoir un ou deux prototypes qui
vont être consacrés à l'art ce qu'on
appelle la fonction feu c'est-à-dire
bien vérifier que le char tir qu'il tire
juste qu'il voit bien qu'il détecte bien
ses cibles et qui met les obus dans les
cibles et puis enfin que l'on simplifie
qui subit les pires agressions qui est
le prototype qui est destiné à vérifier
que le blindage tient bon donc on prend
un char complet on le met sur un
polygone de tir et on tire avec tout ce
que l'ennemi est censé lancer sur le
char dans une phase de combat et à notre
grande satisfaction aucun trou n'a été
fait
de 1982 à 1990 les ingénieurs vont sans
cesse améliorer les performances du
nouvel engin le futur chars allait
l'être
il sera baptisé leclerc en 1986
nous voulons un matériel léger compact
évolutif et c'est un slogan qui qui a
donc un grand intérêt opérationnel nous
y reviendront peut-être mais qui pour
l'ingénieur a été a permis finalement de
guider tous les choix
tous les choix de deux architectures
mécanique de de ce matériel mon
expérience en tant qu'utilisateur de ce
magnifique engin qui et c'est clair
l'engin peut-être pas le meilleur char
du même parce que le meilleur joueur du
monde ça n'existe pas ça dépend du
théâtre d'opérations ça dépend des
circonstances
mais au moins au titre des performances
motorisation conduite de tir et systèmes
de commande ans est le plus performant
du monde
le châssis reste de conception
relativement classique
on trouve ainsi à l'avant gauche le
poste de pilotage à l'avant-droit un
barillet rotatif de munitions au centre
le compartiment de combat de la tourelle
et à l'arrière
le groupe propulseur
les départs de caisse recouvrant les
chenilles permettent de stocker de
nombreux équipements et constituent des
espaces protégés sous l'adage que
châssis du ro place et un châssis tout à
fait qu'il était bien puisque c'est lui
qui a servi à toutes les
expérimentations sur le châssis à fond
euros pour valider le concept de l'engin
à savoir l'ip le moteur hyperbare qu'un
sont fous le groupe motopropulseur
élément clé du leclerc se compose d'un
moteur diesel v8 x à quatre temps et à
suralimentation refroidi de type
hyperbare la cylindrée et de 16,47
litres
là où un simple turbo multiplie par
environ deux fois et demie les
performances
le procédé hyperbare permet lui de
multiplier par sept les performances du
moteur d'origine
de plus ce procédé offre la possibilité
d'avoir à disposition une grande
puissance de façon quasi instantanée
le leclerc peut ainsi passer de 0 à 30
km/heure en 5 secondes et demie rouler à
72 km heure vers l'avant et à 38 km
heure vers l'arrière
la barre mythique des 1500 chevaux
allait être franchie la boîte de
mécanismes aux boîtes de vitesses ou
ms500 permet au leclerc d'avoir une
grande souplesse dans les rapports les
freins du leclerc utilise une
technologie dérivée de la formule 1 à
base d'éléments de friction en carbone
leclerc lancé à pleine vitesse peut
ainsi freiné sur quelques mètres
le train de roulement du leclerc est
assez simple il comprend de chaque côté
deux couronnes 2 barbotin si paire de
demis galets 5 galets de soutien une
poulie de tension et un vérin de tension
hydraulique
le leclerc est équipé d'une chenille à
connecteur à corps en aluminium elle en
six ans 35 mm de largeur la largeur
standard autant
la suspension du char leclerc a été
choisie suivant à critères extrêmement
précis qui était la stabilité au tir
puisque le char leclerc comme vous le
savez et fut le premier char au monde
conçu pour pouvoir tirer normalement
alors qu'il roule à très haute vitesse
en tout terrain
on comprendra comprend facilement que la
première vertu de la suspension est de
stabiliser le char de ta sorte le canon
puisse viser correctement sans trop de
vibrations du mouvement la suspension
est équipé de l'élément de suspension
oléopneumatique ou esso ces 12es au 6 de
chaque côté un proto l'eau claire une
grande stabilité à grande vitesse de
plus la fixation extérieur des os os
facilite grandement la maintenance les
tests réalisés avec les différents vae
h&m ou véhicules expérimentaux à haute
mobilité donnèrent toute satisfaction
aussi bien en termes de vitesse pure et
de souplesse en tout terrain qu'en terme
de freinage de franchissement ou de
maniabilité
il ne restait plus qu'armé la bête
plusieurs concepts de tourelles vont
être étudiées par le giat
il y a six grands projets certains très
avancés avec un armement superstructures
et trois hommes d'équipage et d'autres
plus conventionnel en tourelle classique
avec quatre hommes la tourelle du
leclerc est une tourelle deux hommes le
troisième homme traditionnel des
tourelles habituel a été remplacé par un
chargement automatique qui est située à
l'arrière de la tourelle cette tour elle
a été conçue pour optimiser la
performance de tir en marche du char
leclerc la tourelle retenue d'un poids
d'environ 18 tonnes en ordre de combat
sera conventionnelle est occupée par
deux hommes la rotation électrique de
tours elle se fera la vitesse maximale
de 40 degrés de gisements à la seconde
et le pointage en site de 30° à la
seconde tour elle est ce qu'on appelle
dans notre jargon stabiliser deux axes
suivants l'axé vertical et suivant l'axé
horizontal et permet aux canons de
rester en direction de la cible
quelles que soient les mouvements du
terrain et un système qu'on appelle un
système conduite de tir automatique
la tornade prévenir je les lui a l'air
un exercice vous pointez la tourelle
dans jeu le direction de l'est la classe
se tourne autour c'est impressionnant le
champ peuvent d'une façon aléatoire au
gré du pilote
latourelle conserve toujours la même
direction le canon implanté dans cette
tourelle serein 120 mm de 50 de calibre
soit six mètres 24 ha ha milices chromé
et à culasse verticale ce canon et est
architecturé autour du tir mao du tir en
marche
il est donc équilibré dans son mouvement
en site et il a également été optimisé
pour la tourelle du leclerc en cela que
son recul est très limité et compatible
du chargement automatique
la mise à feu et électriques
l'évacuation des gaz du tir se fait par
surpression de l'habitacle
au moment du tir le canon aura un recul
de 400 mm dans la tourelle la grande
spécificité du char leclerc c'est son
chargement automatique de munitions dans
le char leclerc l'équipage est réduit à
trois hommes et l'absence ou le retrait
de ce quatrième homme a une influence
tout à fait considérable sur l'
architecture du char ça permet de gagner
des tonnes et ça permet de gagner
plusieurs mètres cubes sur sur le char
et 7,7 m a été remplacée par une machine
de robots qui charge directement les
obus dans le canon et c'est ce qui
permet aux chars leclerc de pouvoir
renouveler le tir et de soutenir une
cadence de tir tout à fait phénoménal la
cadence de tir du leclerc est prévu pour
10 tirs à la minute à l'arrêt et six
tirs à la minute en mouvement
22 au but sont chargés dans le barillet
automatique et 18 autres sont stockés
dans le châssis à la sortie du canon
l'obus part à la vitesse effarante de
1800 mètres par seconde
la conduite de tir associé au canon et à
son chargement automatique des obus
offre leclerc des possibilités
extraordinaires
une fois la cible repérer la séquence
appeler derry soit détection
reconnaissance identification est lancé
si la cible et qui identifiait
positivement les ordinateurs vont
calculer la fenêtre de tir
c'est à dire le moment optimal de mise à
feu en prenant en compte les principaux
paramètres à la fois de la cible et du
char tireur tout ceci s'effectue dans un
délai extrêmement court et l'acquisition
d'un but futur c'est à dire de l'endroit
où la cible serein et non pas l'endroit
où la cible paix prend à peine quelques
secondes
le leclerc
grâce à tous ces systèmes perfectionnés
peut toucher en roulant une cible de la
taille d'une affiche publicitaire à
presque 4 km de distance
le leclerc est servie par un équipage de
trois hommes le chef de char est assis à
gauche dans la tourelle son rôle
principal consiste à faire évoluer le
char en opération en liaison avec les
autres chars et à prendre les décisions
tactiques nécessaires son pupitre de
commande centralise toutes les
informations relayées par l'électronique
son poste est accessible par une trappe
située sur le dessus de la tourelle le
tireur est assis à droite dans la
tourelle
il est chargé de repérer les cibles de
les identifier et de transmettre les
informations aux chefs de chars le
tireur est aussi en liaison constante
avec le chef de char par l'intermédiaire
de l'électronique embarquée son poste
est accessible par une trappe située sur
le dessus de la tourelle c'est un
système extrêmement performant qu'on
appelle hunter un donneur le chasseur et
le tueur faire que le chasseur voit les
cibles les désigne au tireur qui s'en
charge et au fur et à mesure seul chef
de char qui redessine la cible suivante
pendant que le tireur n'a fait que de
tirer et donc là il ya une répartition
optimum de
des capacités en tourelle
le pilote est assis dans la caisse à la
main gauche il est chargé de conduire le
char et de s'occuper de la mécanique
il peut recevoir directement sur son
pupitre de commande les instructions
d'itinéraires envoyé par le chef de char
son poste est accessible par une trappe
située sur le toit de caisse pvp puppy
devises à sion pilote sur lequel on a
tout ce qu'on a sur un compteur normaux
de n'importe quel véhicule la vitesse du
véhicule le jauge carburant le contour
moteur les éléments d'affichage de
l'état batterie du char et puis un
certain nombre de boutons poussoirs pour
pouvoir appeler ou raser ou effacer les
différents messages qui apparaît sur le
bandeau ici la protection du leclerc est
composé de blindage multicouches
performant modulaire composite et
compact ses blindages sont faciles à
produire industriellement et aisé à
remplacer même partiellement sur le
leclerc le savoir faire des ateliers de
la mx permet donc au leclerc de disposer
d'un blindage à l'épreuve des armes
antichars adverse mais aussi de pouvoir
évoluer dans le temps en fonction de la
menace rencontrer le char leclerc a été
le premier char qui fut conçu avec des
blindages amovible alors ça ne veut sans
doute pas dire grand chose pour pour le
grand public mais c'est très important
pour la vie opérationnelle d'achard
puisque je rappelle qu'un char est en
service pendant une trentaine d'années
donc on imagine bien que la menace les
projectiles adverses font des progrès
continus au cours de ses 30 ans et un
blindage qui a été conçu dans les années
80 pour faire face à des projectiles
donné 80 ne sera plus tout à fait aussi
résistant vingt ans après nous pouvons d
billets littéralement le char leclerc de
ses blindages ce sont des blocs de
matériaux composites que nous pouvons
retirer très facilement dans un atelier
et est remplacé par deux nouveaux le
canon du leclerc utilise plusieurs types
de munitions
chacune ayant un rôle bien déterminé les
munitions flèches sont destinés à la
destruction des charlots les obus
polyvalents sont plutôt destinés à la
destruction de cibles faiblement blindés
et à des fins anti personnel des
munitions spécifiques sont aussi prévus
pour la destruction de bâtiments et des
ouvrages fortifiés des munitions
d'exercice et de manipulations sont
aussi prévus
le système de défense rapprochée repose
sur une mitrailleuse coaxial de 12.7 mm
montés sur le berceau du câlin lui sans
coûts sont prévues dans la dotation de
la 12e il s'est tu
de plus quatre lanceurs fumigènes ainsi
que trois lanceurs de défense anti
fantassins sont installés sur le toit de
tourelles cpo sont des lances fumigènes
c'est le système gallix qui permet de
masquer les charentes quelques dixièmes
de seconde par d'autres souplesse des
poids qui est opaque au visible et à la
france
il est aussi prévu quatre lanceurs
verticaux destinés à leurrer d'éventuels
missiles antichars à guidage infrarouge
le leclerc a une autonomie de 470 km
assurée par des réservoirs de 1300
litres 2 biteau largable de 200 litres
chacun porte cette autonomie à 610 km
sur ses deux boutons là c'est ce qu'on
appelle largage bidon on est capable de
rajouter sur le char pour les
déplacements stratégique long des bidons
supplémentaires de carburant qui sont
accrochés à l'arrière des chars qui se
vide par gravité dans les réservoirs du
char pour les premières centaines de
kilomètres parcourus par le char et
lorsqu'on a vidé les bidons mais c'est
un petit peu gênant pour les rotations
tourelles on a un système de largage
automatique qui permet de jeter ses
bidons qui sont récupérés a par la suite
par la logistique
les ingénieurs ont étudié le leclerc
afin que la maintenance soient
simplifiées au maximum
il est possible de changer un moteur en
80 minutes la centrale de freinage en 60
minutes
le chargement automatique en cent
cinquante minutes les caractéristiques
finales du leclerc sont un point de 56
tonnes une longueur de 9 m 87 une
largeur maximale de 3 mètres 71 une
hauteur de deux mètres cinquante trois
au toit de tourelles
le premier char leclerc dit de série est
sorti fin 1990 décembre 1991
mais la partie je dirais
de développement du char proprement dit
n'a démarré qu'au début des années 80
donc il nous a fallu il nous a fallu
globalement huit ans entre le moment où
les premiers démonstrateurs ont été
présentés aux services techniques et le
moment où le char leclerc de série dans
sa définition dans sa configuration
définitive est sorti du lit le premier
prototype du char leclerc sera dévoilée
en 1990 au salon de satory dès le début
de l'année 1992
les premiers exemplaires de série
allaient être livrés à l'armée française
la carrière opérationnelle et
commerciale du leclerc allait débuter
où
le char leclerc sera présenté au monde
dans les divers salons de vente de
matériels militaires lors de ces salons
le char leclerc sera évalué par les
différents pays
l'un d'entre eux les émirats arabes unis
où elle a eu après avoir éliminé le
concurrent direct du char français
le m abrams va acheter à la france un
contingent important de chars leclerc le
groupe nexter a produit quatre cent six
chars pour l'armée française et a
produit 3 188 chars pour notre principal
client export qui sont les émirats
arabes unis j'ai été dans mon passé le
chef de projet et responsable de
développement du cher diva eu c'est à
dire le char export qui a été kidnappé
dans la spécifité et l emmener au chaud
et il a fallu rajouter un certain nombre
de fonctionnalités type climatisation au
delà de ça le char de base était capable
dans ces spécifications d'aller pour
l'armée française au froid ou chaud donc
on lui a amené une climatisation et puis
après on a traduit simplement tout ce
qui est écrit dedans dans la langue
qu'ils allaient bien pour que
l'opérateur puisse le lire
les chars leclerc eux a eu seront livrés
dès 1994
ils seront ensuite utilisées au kosovo
en coopération avec les chars leclerc
français
donc au total à peu près 800 chars
auquel il convient de rajouter une
cinquantaine de chars de dépannage dont
des chars leclerc de dépannage qui sont
une version dérivée du char de combat
pour porter assistance et réparer le
char qui ont été endommagées sur le
champ de bataille les leclerc fourni à
l'armée française est destinée à
moderniser le parc blindés
principalement composés d'amx 30 et 32
vont être organisées en régiment blindé
appelé rc 80 les airs c'est 80 seront
composés de 80 leclerc répartis en deux
groupes d'escadron de 40 leclerc chacun
les j'ai eu 40 chaque j'ai eu 40 est
composé d'un leclerc de commandement et
de trois escadrons de treize chars
chacun chaque escadron comprend trois
pelotons de quatre chars et un char
capitelles
l'armée française dispose aujourd'hui de
quatre r c'est 80 soit 320 chars leclerc
enrégimentés ses régiments sont le 501e
et le 503e rcc régiment de chars de
combat à mourmelon le premier et
deuxième
rch régiment de chasseurs à verdun le
sixième et douzième rc régiment de
cuirassiers à olivet le premier est 11e
rc régiment de cuirassiers à carpiagne
le leclerc peut engager ses adversaires
en mouvement alors que lui même est en
mouvement et ce en même temps le char
est capable de détruire six adversaires
qui bouge en une seule minute
ce qui veut dire qu'on en revient une
conception traditionnelle de la
cavalerie de la charge sabre etc et
d'une façon générale la souplesse
tactique du du leclerc induit une
mobilité tactique particulièrement
remarquable sur le champ de la taille
crc 80 sont des unités mobiles
totalement autonome est particulièrement
adapté à des missions à l'étranger
les chars leclerc du 501e et 503e
régiment de chars de combat seront
utilisés dans le cadre du maintien de la
paix au kosovo
dès 1999 cette opération correspondait à
la volonté politique internationale
d'éviter toute aggravation de la
situation dans la région
là où les blindés légers classique de
type vbl ouvéa b ne suffisait plus à
calmer les forces en présence les chars
leclerc ont suffi à calmer une situation
orageuse par leur simple présence
dissuasive
les chars leclerc ont été utilisés sur
le terrain avec un taux de disponibilité
dépassant les 90% ce qui confirme la
grande fiabilité des matériels engagés
lors de cette opération les chars
leclerc sont passés partout y compris à
des endroits où certains disaient qu'il
ne passerait jamais l'opération a débuté
par un débarquement en grèce dans le
port de thessalonique
les chars leclerc ont ensuite été
acheminés en ep b engin porte blindée
jusqu'à la frontière du kosovo
ils ont achevé leur déploiement opératif
en faisant le dernier déplacement
jusqu'à mitrovic à en empruntant routes
et chemins en compagnie de leurs engins
de soutien
la présence des forces internationales
de la kfor au kosovo et notamment des
chars leclerc a permis de maintenir dans
la région une paix relative les chars
leclerc ont ainsi prouvé au monde qu'ils
étaient capables d'assurer des missions
autre que guerrière
le char pourrait donc tout aussi bien
être utilisée dans de longues percée au
long du dispositif d'un dispositif
adverse percée stratégique à 100 120 km
par jour sont des choses qui sont
imaginables dès lors que la logistique
suit effectivement ou hochart peut-être
employés dans d'autres types de tâches
c'est la grande nouveauté l'utilisation
notamment dans des opérations de
missions de maintien de la paix ça a été
le cas au kosovo c'est à présent le cas
au liban au sud-liban des leclerc sont
engagés avec la finul renforcée
l'objectif dans ce cadre là est de créer
une puissance de feu potentiel
suffisamment importante pour empêcher un
adversaire de vouloir jouer les
fanfarons
l'intervention des chars leclerc au
liban fait elle aussi partie des
missions de maintien de la paix dévolu
aux forces internationales
les chars leclerc seront ainsi engagé au
sud liban dans le cadre d'une mission de
sécurisation d'une zone tampon à la
frontière israélienne
encore une fois la seule présence des
chars leclerc a suffi à calmer les
esprits et à maintenir le calme entre
les éventuels belligérants la présence
pression c'est pour calmer les joueurs
mer le char leclerc âgée au combat
l'impression de force et de puissance
dégagée par ces engins et le respect
qu'ils imposent sont extrêmement
dissuasif et sont donc la meilleure
garantie du maintien de la paix la
conception du char du futur est à
l'étude
les données en sont encore
confidentielles mais il est prévu que ce
char sera à la fois un acteur et un
capteur d'information il est en effet
reconnu aujourd'hui que le camp qui
dispose du plus grand nombre
d'informations fiables a de fortes
chances de remporter la victoire
à cette fin le futur chars évoluera sur
un champ de bataille totalement
numérisée en liaison constante avec le
commandement opérationnel les autres
chars de son unité et tous les autres
acteurs actifs de l'engagement comme les
autres véhicules et les fantassins
si nous devions aujourd'hui refaire un
char je pense que l'accent serait mis
sur ce que l'on appelle la numérisation
du char donc en clair faire du char à la
fois un acteur du champ de bataille en
tant que destructeur d'ennemis mais
aussi un capteur
les échanges de données se fera en temps
réel entre tous les acteurs afin de
faciliter la prise de décision tactique
immédiate
ce char est prévu pour être mises en
service à l'horizon 2015 en revanche une
version améliorée du char leclerc et
déjà étudié et tester cette version est
appelé le leclerc 2010 houchard azur
azur comme adaptation aux actions à une
fois leur zone alors le char azur
justement préfigure un peu ce que nous
pensons être le char de demain le char
azur est tout simplement un char leclerc
de base sur lequel nous avons apporté un
certain nombre de modifications et
d'équipements justement pour le rendre
plus aptes qu'il n'est aujourd'hui à
intervenir dans la zone urbaine une des
difficultés de la zone urbaine c'est
d'être compartimenté ce qui fait que une
ce que l'on appelle une une bataille
urbaine n'est en fait que la somme de
dizaines voire de centaines de micro
bataille qui se passe à l'échelon d'un
bloc d'immeubles ou houda pâté de
maisons les grandes caractéristiques du
char restent les mêmes seuls quelques
modifications ont été faites
il est destiné à être utilisé pour des
actions en zone urbaine et plus
particulièrement dans le cadre d'actions
de dissuasion de maintien de la paix ou
d' aide aux populations
il ya trois types d'amélioration sur
leclaire en zone urbaine et à des
améliorations de type protection du char
qui sont effectivement des blindages
spécifique rapporté pour les
les agressions zones urbaines qui sont
la protection d ouverture du char
puisque malheureusement un char n'est
pas fait pour être approché à partir de
mon approche
on peut envoyer dans différentes
ouvertures du char des cocktails molotov
et autres projectiles enflammés
donc on protège ça et puis à charge
comme leclerc et on va dire pas
forcément protéger la zone urbaine parce
qu'il n'a pas une vision parfaite de
tout ce qui est très proche de lui
puisque c'est un engin qui est fait pour
agresser en frontal des d'autres chats
entre 2 3 à 4000 mètres donc de nos
chars la capacité de voix de surveiller
autour de lui par des systèmes de vision
360° donc ça c'est les éléments de
protection le chaland zones urbaines par
par rapport aux chars en zones ouvertes
a besoin de travailler avec une grande
coopération avec les ce qu'on appelle
les éléments débarquer tous les éléments
les fantassins qui sont autour du char
il faut à la fois qu'ils puissent
travailler avec eux en coopération avec
eux et à la fois qu'ils ne risquent pas
de blesser les fantassins alors on a
ajouté aussi aux chars pour la zone
urbaine
à tournon
piloté de l'intérieur du char avec une
caméra joue aux caméras nuit et une
mitrailleuse spéciale sur laquelle on
peut mettre de larmes
l'étal non létales ou à létalité réduite
en fonction de ce qui se passe dans la
zone urbaine on se sert du chat pour
apporter les éléments débarqué en ville
deux éléments logistiques
supplémentaires donc on a fait sur ce
char des questions l'apport
supplémentaire donc ils transportent
plus de 400 kg de matériel des brancards
des jerricanes d'eau des munitions
supplémentaires qui est capable
d'appâter en ville et de larguer de
manière automatique sans personnes
sortent du char pour donner ça au
fantassin ce qu'on ne voit peut-être pas
parce que c'est très discret sur la
guerre de la tourelle il ya de petites
antennes c'est à peu près de cette
taille là qui font partie du système de
communication sans fil est ce que les
opérateurs qui sont au sol
certains en or les chefs de groupe ou un
kit oreillette qui leur permet d'être en
communication constante jusqu'à 200
mètres du char avec l'ensemble l'équipe
a du chat pour pouvoir mener l'opération
coordonnée
le char leclerc a été camouflés et
marqué de diverses façons
selon les théâtres d'opérations où il a
été engagé le char leclerc utilisé en
métropole et camouflé de façon
habituelle dans les trois couleurs
standardisée de l'otan le vert le noir
et le beige clair des noms de baptême
identifiant chaque char seront apposés
sur chaque côté de la tourelle un
symbole tactique et une immatriculation
seront placés à l'arrière et à l'avant
de la caisse
le char leclerc utilisé au kosovo a été
camouflés en trois couleurs de type
autant le vert le noir et le marron
foncé là aussi des noms de baptême
identifiant chaque char seront apposés
sur chaque côté de la tourelle un
symbole tactique et une immatriculation
seront placés à l'arrière et à l'avant
de la caisse un grand marquage kfor
blanc sera placés de chaque côté du char
sur le bas de caisse lors de l'hiver au
kosovo des larges bandes blanches seront
peintes sur le camouflage des chars
permettant de mieux les camoufler dans
les paysages enneigés en configuration
désertique
le char leclerc a été camouflés en deux
couleurs de type autant le beige clair
et le marron foncé là encore des noms de
baptême identifiant chaque char seront
apposés sur chaque côté de la tourelle
le char leclerc azur sera camouflet pour
faire face aux nouvelles missions en
milieu urbanisé le camouflage prévu sera
appliquée en différents tons de gris de
beige et de blanc sous formes
géométriques afin de mieux se fondre
dans un environnement urbain dense
le char leclerc est encore trop récent
pour être présentée dans les musées
étrangers
il est en revanche possible de voir deux
chars leclerc au musée des blindés à
saumur le premier est un exemplaire
classique du char leclerc de première
série
il se trouve exposée dans la cour
d'entrée du musée
le deuxième exemplaire est beaucoup plus
intéressant il s'agit en effet du
quatrième prototype baptisé du rock
il a été utilisé pour la mise au point
du char leclerc cet exemplaire a servi à
tester les capacités du châssis et de la
suspension du futur chars en situation
réelle sur le terrain
la tourelle est factice et a été
construite en bois à bien le char
leclerc dans les années qui viennent va
évoluer
là aussi selon les deux dimensions
traditionnels qui font l'évolution de
matériaux il faut voir que ces matériels
là ont une durée de vie de plusieurs
dizaines d'années je pense qu'en leclerc
entre le début de sa conception et puis
le retrait du service du dernier
matériel ça sera peut-être 70 ans donc
scellé il est à peine au milieu de sa
vie actuellement et donc on voit bien
que pendant ses très nombreuses années
il faut à la fois tenir compte de
l'évolution de la menace donc des gens
qu'on est censé contrer et puis aussi de
l'évolution de la technologie et donc
c'est le mariage la combinaison de ces
deux de ces deux évolutions la menace
d'un côté et l'évolution technologique
deux autres qui permet effectivement de
disposer à tout instant doit tout moment
en toute période du matériel le mieux
adapté en fonction de l'évolution
technique à la menace qui se présente je
pense que le leclerc avec la base que
nous lui connaissons sera un matériel
qui a encore de très très longues années
très nombreuses années devant lui
ouais
ski
ce
oh
mon vieux tu es sûr tardy et andré je
travaille chez nexter je suis pilote
d'essai
je suis rentré ici c'est en 1973
donc ça fait plus de cinq ans
bahin dijon c'est quand même un peu plus
un peu plus rôle de puissance déjà et
puis bon une fois qu'on a le gabarit du
véhicule en tête ça pose aucun problème
à passer n'importe où
ah bah pour tous qui échoue y ait
effectivement le char leclerc c'est
quand même
enfin pour moi c'est très bien au niveau
suspension même ce soit dans les trous
en terrain surtout internet
bah j'ai sous la main directement sur
moi donc j'ai volant ensuite le côté sur
le côté gauche et le pvp provisions
pilote tout le contour vitesse les
messages qui peuvent arriver
et et après j'ai donc mon écran de
contrôle avec tous les instruments qui
me permet de mettre le véhicule en route
c'est une boîte donc automatique voies
hydrauliques ya un volant tout à fait le
volant donc une de frein il
d'accélérateur
c'est oui c'est très puissant et surtout
qu'on peut frère à huit fermes un
démarrage très rapide en un clash
convertissent